figaro live il est 15h 9 15h09 à paris
parce qu'il est 9h09 du matin à fairfax
aux états unis faire fax et en virginie
et c'est là que se tient le procès du
siècle c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont
les américains alors sans doute pas le
procès le plus important ça non mais
mais très certainement le plus
médiatique parce que depuis le 11 avril
dernier c'est un grand déballage auquel
nous assistons un peu médusé 1 c'est
vrai entre entre l'acteur johnny depp et
son ex femme amber heard on va tout vous
expliquer elle va tout vous expliquer
que le retrait de mme anne bonjour vous
êtes vous êtes journaliste au figaro
madame
madame figaro d'ailleurs je montre
madame figaro de ce week-end il est là
merci de m'accompagner alors vous avez
tout suivi de 2,7 de cette affaire
prenons les choses dans l'ordre si vous
le voulez bien il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas forcément entendu parler de la
sphère qui savent pas que ça existe il y
en a qui savent qui est un procès en ce
moment aux états unis mettions pas tous
les tenants et les aboutissants et
expliquez moi cette histoire depuis le
début amber r&d johnny depp ils ont été
mariés c'est ça ils se sont rencontrés
comment raconter mois alors ils se sont
rencontrés en fait en 2009 sur le tour
couple donc amber heard et bisexuels
graf et johnny depp est en couple encore
avec vanessa paradis oui alors ça c'est
un couple qu'on connaît bien en france
donc
ultra médiatisé est en fête amber heard
et johnny depp ne vont officialiser leur
relation qu'en 2012 d'accord et donc à
partir de 2012 il sait comment la
contamination dégénère
c'est à dire alors qu'est ce qui se
passe à partir de 2013 il ya des rumeurs
de dispute violente entre les deux
d'accord rigal qui seront évoqués plus
tard dans un procès notamment 2013
deux se seraient disputés en raison d'un
tatouage de l'acteur c'est du moins ce
que la wii on en est là on en est sûr
sur ce genre de dispute alors on va
rentrer dans les détails donc ils
s'engueulent et alors ils séparent ce
saint vous un moment alors à ce moment
là ils sont toujours ensemble et ils se
fiancent en 2014 d'accord ah oui
d'accord ils se fiancent ok très bien
réconcilie se fiance et ils se marient
en 2015 en qu'il ya deux mariages qui
sont célébrés et auquel en fait déjà la
fille de johnny depp ville rose la fille
de vanessa paradis et de vanessa par
tafer pour que l'on se comprenne bien on
n'a pas forcément la généalogie de
chacun d'accord donc lagarde ont réagi
thierry élire aux dates ne vient pas et
d'y lire aux dettes ne vient pas parce
que comme le dit johnny depp dans le
procès actuel elle n'est pas en très bon
terme il n'explique pas exactement
pourquoi mais une part en très bons
termes avec sa belle-mère d'accord donc
il se marie on se dit qu'à ce moment là
tout va bien on se dit qu'à ce moment là
tout va bien mais en mai 2016 amber
heard demande le divorce d'accord donc
douze ans après ça je le calcul un an
après son amant et et le la demande de
divorce est accompagnée d'un dépôt de
plainte
dans lequel elle dit avoir subi des
violences conjugales de la part de
johnny depp d'accord et donc elle
demande une ordonnance restrictive à
l'encontre de johnny depp
donc ça c'est à la fin de leur mariage
il divorce et elle demande une
ordonnance restrictive mais ensuite tout
à fait et ensuite en août ils
parviennent tous les deux à un accord
finalement à l'amiable malgré tous ces
rebondissements ils arrivent à se mettre
d'accord et johnny depp accepte de
verser 7 millions de dollars à amber
heard qui parvient c'est une somme c'est
une sacrée somme et
et amber heard promet néanmoins de
reverser cette somme à des associations
caritatives dont une association qui
lutte contre les violences conjugales
qui aide les victimes de violences
conjugales alors on verra ensuite que
cette somme je n'étais l'accusent de ne
pas la voir verser à des oeuvres
caritatives bon on se dit qu'à ce moment
là tout est bien qui finit bien même si
les termes sont un peu galvaudé mais bon
on passe à autre chose non toujours pas
alors en janvier 2017 le divorce il est
effectivement définitivement prononcé on
se dit que cette histoire est terminée
mais finalement en juin 2018 le sun sort
un article dans lequel il est qui le
qualifie johnny depp de mari violent le
sun journal anglais qui est un tabloïd
anglais tout à fait presse de la presse
à scandale qualifie donc johnny depp de
mari violent et là par contre johnny
depp est déterminé à poursuivre
l'éditeur du sun en justice donc il y
aura un premier procès d'être mieux trop
ce qu'il ya lieu si je me trompe pas en
2020 à londres c'est ça tout à fait le
premier procès à l'ue en 2020 à londres
et le procès actuel reprend beaucoup
d'éléments de ce procès du cndd alors en
revanche ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que là ce procès il concerne
johnny depp est en berne le 5 c'est
terminé pour quoi ils sont ensemble à
nouveau face à face devant la justice
qu'est ce qui se passe parce qu'à la
base amber heard et presque se dédouane
de ça c'est le sun qui accuse c'est pas
elle pourquoi ils sont face à face en ce
moment alors en ce moment donc ça
concerne
notre histoire c'est ça se passe en
décembre 2018
amber heard publié une tribune
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que ça se passe
à fairfax parce que c'est là qui est
imprimé le washington post et amber
heard écrit une tribune pour le
washington post en 2018 alors elle ne
cite pas johnny depp mais elle accuse f1
elle dit en tout cas qu'elle est victime
de violences conjugales donc si je
résume il ya un procès qui va se tenir à
londres de johnny depp qui porte plainte
contre le sound pour diffamation et à ce
moment là il se rend compte qu il ya une
tribune d'embarras dans le washington
post qui se dit victime de violences
conjugales
sans accuser johnny depp mais johnny
depp se dit c'est trop visible on
comprend que c'est moi et ils décident
de la poursuivre le problème c'est qu'en
fait quelques jours après là c'est ce
que dit johnny depp quelques jours après
la parution de cette tribune il est
évincé de la saga pirates des caraïbes
ah oui alors ça c'est pas rien donc je
pense que ça a pu peut-être motivé sa
décision de déposer plainte en
diffamation
et là ils demandent 50 millions de
dollars de dommages et intérêts à amber
heard vous voyez cette cet article que
vous avez publié chloé friedman de
madame figaro vous avez toutes les infos
voir si vous voulez reprendre dans
l'ordre le déroulé de ce procès dont on
va parler là dans la dans la prochaine
demi heure vous avez tous assurent sur
madame figaro alors clos et on a le
cadre donc on arrive le 11 avril c'est
bien ça date du début de ce2 ce procès
et là c'est le procès du siècle c'est
extrêmement médiatique expliquez moi
comment ça se passe pourquoi les
américains se passionnent les audiences
c'est un peu fou alors c'est
complètement enfin inédit dans son
ampleur il ya des gens qui sont
accrochés à leur écran tous les jours à
suivre le les rebondissements du procès
parce qu'il y en a toulouse tous les
jours en fait
donc il ya 3 chaîne américaine qui
diffuse le procès en direct
donc il ya des caméras donc on voit les
images de l'arrivée d'alors ça on
connaît en france les images d'arrivée
mais vous allez voir vont passer des
images à l'intérieur du tribunal ça
c'est parfaitement interdit en france
aux états unis ça se fait aux états unis
ça se fait mais les procès
ultramédiatisé sont plutôt des procès de
deux faits divers donc avec des acteurs
qui sont des protagonistes plutôt qu'ils
sont qui deviennent connus au fil du
procès d'accord les procès
ultra-médiatisé de célébrités par
exemple angelina jolie et brad pitt on
n'assiste pas aux aux audiences on n'est
pas aussi directement dans la salle dans
les tribunaux d'accord donc là c'est
vraiment très particulier parce que j'ai
d'autres exemples 1 ogi simpson le
joueur de foot américain phil spector le
producteur de musique alors kelly le
chanteur rappeur c'est une habitude
presque américaine ça de diffuser les
pros cette passionnée pour ce genre de
déballage oui c'est devenu petit à petit
une sorte d'habitude après de cette
ampleur c'est quand même
un procès de cette ampleur dans lequel
chacun suit les rebondissements tous les
jours c'est quand même très rare mais ça
a été un peu facilité par
par là les émissions de télé réalité
notamment qui maintenant arrive
directement dans les dents les cours des
tribunaux et filmé les procès etc etc
oui ça a été popularisé ces derniers
temps alors pour tout vous dire le
premier grand procès parce que j'ai lu
ça je me suis penché c'est peut-être
bundy c'était la première diffusion
nationale d'un procès dans les années 80
tels bundy c'était un tueur en série
c'est vous dire si les américains se
passionnent pour ce genre pour ce genre
d'affaires et surtout pour ces procès
diffusé je salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent vous n'hésitez pas vous
laisser votre votre commentaire sur
youtube sur lefigaro.fr on vous lit on
essaye de répondre à toutes ces
questions et moi j'en ai une
chloé parce que je crois que johnny depp
tout le monde sait à peu près qui les
pirates des caraïbes il a fait d'autres
séries bien avant il est très connu mais
on bavarde c'est qui alors en dehors
d'elles est assez connue aux états unis
elle a à jouer d'abord elle a commencé
sa carrière au début des années 2000
elle a joué d'abord d'ondés dans des
séries type newport beach ensuite elle a
joué dans quelques films comme friday
night lights mais sa renommée est arrivé
notamment en 2009 avec rhum express et
le film avec johnny depp et par la suite
lorsqu'elle à intégrer l'univers dc avec
justice league et c'est en 2007 oui
parce que l aidant dans cette mouvance
là elle est dans le comment dit le
blockbuster c'est ce qu'elle fait en ce
moment amber heard elle est plutôt dans
le blockbuster surtout dans aquaman dans
lequel elle joue aux côtés de jason
momoa en 2018
c'est ça surtout qui part fait un peu sa
renommée mais aux états unis elle n'a
pas l'aura par exemple d'une angine
angelina jolie alors on va on va essayer
d'avancer on va aller dans le fond dans
le fond de la faire si vous le voulez
bien je voudrais qu'on commence par la
question des violences physiques parce
que on avance on vous allez comprendre
petit à petit que il a des choses un peu
un peu particulière et un déballage un
peu un peu sordide qui peut nous faire
rire parfois mais cette question des
violences conjugales elle est sérieuse
elle est importante amber heard accuse
johnny depp de l'avoir frappée c'est ça
tout à fait alors il ya d'abord cette
histoire de dispute en 2013 durant
laquelle ils se seraient
engagés dans ce conflit en raison d'un
tatouage de johnny depp dédié à winona
ryder
et winona ryder expliquez moi cette
histoire alors winona ryder c'est une
ancienne qu'on paie c'est une actrice
c'est une ancienne compagne johnny
d'accord avant vanessa paradis après
alors que dans les années 90 avant avant
vanessa paradis donc c'est un tatouage
qu'il a depuis longtemps c'est un vieux
tatouage alors à l'origine il y avait
écrit winona forever d'accord il a
remplacé sa un espèce de petit clin
d'oeil en enlevant le napt et ça dis oui
ninon forever ce qui veut dire en
français le vin pour toujours d'accord
et donc amber heard se serait moqué de
ce tatouage et elles l'accusent de à ce
moment-là de l'avoir giflée à plusieurs
reprises
donc ça c'est le vraiment là où tout
commence et ensuite il semble que ce
soit une escalade donc dans ce procès on
a eu plusieurs d'ailleurs éléments
rabassa des enregistrements audio des
sms quand même assez explicite
où
sont évoqués leur altercation mais il y
en a eu une grande quantité alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il donne pour
sa défense johnny depp lui ont dit qu'il
était alcoolique alors ça est ce que
c'est ça va dans son sens ou pas je suis
pas certain quelle est sa ligne de
défense à johnny depp pour dire bah non
c'est pas vrai est ce que parce qu'il
accuse aussi un bar de le frapper assez
ça il accuse aussi un bar de le frapper
lui c'est pareil a beaucoup d'éléments
de preuve à l'appui
il est très soutenue à hollywood ah oui
alors ça on va on va y venir il est
soutenu à hollywood pourquoi
notamment ses anciennes compagnes
justement dont on parlait donc l'actrice
winona ryder
qui a dit qu'elle n'avait jamais subi de
telles violences de la part de john de
la part de johnny depp vanessa paradis a
fait la même chose elle a dit qu'il
s'était jamais comporté comme ça envers
elle sa fille lily rose depp également à
témoigner javier bardem a pris sa
défense 1 paul bettany également enfin
tous ses amis de hollywood sont vent
debout en faveur de johnny depp alors je
vous propose qu'on l'écouté johnny depp
parce que lui c'est lui qui prend la
parole depuis le début de ce procès puis
après ce sera en dehors je vous propose
qu'on écoute sur la question des
violences conjugales
straka she would et que peggy ce soir
que nous
chauffe
expliquez-nous ce frenchy virement
sur une voisine m'a fait venir au club
et à ses lèvres ne reçoit qu'un seul
[Musique]
johnny depp qui dit je n'ai jamais
frappé de femmes dans la vie mais qu'il
accuse elle de le frapper ça aussi c'est
un point sur lequel ils insistent depuis
le début de ce procès il s'est
clairement décrit comme une victime de
violences conjugales jeune johnny depp
donc il a pilé c'est d'apporter beaucoup
d'éléments de preuve qui justement
témoigne de ce qu'il lui a fait subir
amber heard alors des éléments de des
éléments de preuve on les entend vanessa
paradis est ce que la témoigner dans ce
procès là ou pas alors ce n'était pas
dans ce procès là c'était dans le procès
justement qui oppose et
johnny depp hossein d'accord donc celui
d'il ya presque deux ans tout à fait est
ce qu'elle appelle n'a pas parlé pour
l'instant depuis depuis le début de ce
procès là le 11 avril alors je vais vous
faire écouter dans un instant un
enregistrement qui a été écouté pendant
le pendant le procès j'ai l'impression
qu'il se filmer beaucoup qu'ils
s'enregistrent est beaucoup il ya une
forme de paranoïa des acteurs de lille
ou de l'oit moi je veux enfin si j'ai
des problèmes dans ma vie je ne me filme
pas tous les jours pour essayer de
prouver des choses c'est normal ça c'est
une habitude c'est comme si s'il
anticipait en fait ce qui allait se
passer c'est assez étrange il ya quand
même des photos très trash très
explicite ils ont gardé les échanges de
mails et sms
il ya des enregistrements audio mais
enregistrer directement pendant des
disputes
quand même violente c'est très étonnant
alors justement je vous propose qu'on
écoute l'un de ces enregistrements qui a
été qu'ils étaient diffusées pendant le
procès puis on en parle lui derrière
[Musique]
sérieuse
voilà oui je le suis alors ils
l'accusent en back up de violence
conjugale est ce qu'il donne des
exemples à ce que vous pouvez commencer
à m'en donner et on va avancer
progressivement dans tout ce qui s'est
dit dans dans ce procès alors lui donne
l'exemple notamment d'un incident qui
s'est produit en 2015 qui a quand même
lui aussi assez trash il s'était juste
avant leur mariage il dit qu'en fait
amber heard s'est entretenu avec leurs
avocats au sujet de leur contrat
prénuptial d'accord et que l'entretien
s'est très mal passé visiblement puisque
amber heard était très en colère du ton
sur lequel lui a parlé l'avocat
et c'est ce qui aurait engendré son
conflit avec johnny depp à ce moment là
et en fait à ce moment là dans un accès
de colère elle lance une bouteille de
vodka sur johnny depp
ski et les éclats de la bouteille lui
sectionne un bout de majeur alors je
vous préviens on va commencer à rentrer
dans dans les aspects un peu glauque de
ce procès on en est désolé d'une
certaine manière mais c'est assez
intéressant d'expliquer c'est sans doute
symptomatique de de notre société donc
racontez moi cette histoire du doigt
coupé de johnny depp c'est un majordome
qui retrouve ce doit continuer vous êtes
en train de me dire ça continue doit les
y aller donc le sait ça se passait en
australie d'accord il séjourné dans une
maison dont le majordome est arrivé à la
suite de la dispute et à trouver un
un bout de doigt de johnny depp sous le
barre
et mais également un message écrit en
lettres de sang sur un miroir de la
maison et donc il y avait du sang
partout sur les murs et sur le miroir de
la maison était écrit iloveyou donc donc
je t'aime et le majordome a trouvé la
maison dans cet état alors on imagine on
comprend que c'est quand même très très
particulier je salue tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent et qui s'intéresse à cette
histoire à ce procès assez exceptionnel
entre johnny depp et l'actrice son ex
femme amber heard je vois j'ai beaucoup
de messages de soutien à johnny depp il
a gagné l'opinion publique johnny depp
déjà alors sur tik tok par exemple
hashtag du procès de johnny depp a déjà
4 milliards a été repris 4 milliard de
fois
donc c'est une espèce de d'ampleur
énorme sur les réseaux sociaux sur
twitter il ya énormément de réactions
aussi et effectivement les gens prennent
le parti de johnny depp en majorité
commence au sol
le il a je pense le côté sympathie
engendrés par l'acteur parce qu'en fait
amber heard s'est opposé à ce que ce
procès soit filmé mais pas johnny depp
lui ne s'est jamais opposée et depuis le
début de ce procès le 11 avril
il met en place à lui a été reproché par
certains certains médias d'ailleurs une
espèce de chaud oui alors on va y venir
il est assez rigolo a l'impression qu'il
fait des blagues très souvent une deux
par jour je vois je lis le soir quand je
fais le compte rendu quand je lis le
compte-rendu vos compte rendu fait des
blagues tout temps il fait beaucoup rire
la salle d'ailleurs là ça un peu agacé
la juge a un moment du procès à la
demande et à la salle d' arrêter de rire
ou sous peine de faire sortir des
spectateurs de ce procès parce que
johnny depp
interrogé sur les films qu'il a fait
avant pirates des caraïbes site enfin tu
n as cité des films en dix ans je suis
je suis nul fait preuve de beaucoup
d'autodérision en disant je suis nul je
sais pas quels films cités je me
rappelle même pas et ça ça fait beaucoup
rire la salle et on le voit à plusieurs
reprises dans ce procès sur jouer ces
réactions notamment se retenir de rire
quand le l'avocat de amber heard ed rapp
un peu
donc c'est miss c'est très théâtral
d'une certaine manière et alors on
rappelle que pour l'instant d'ailleurs
expliqué moi pour l'instant johnny depp
prend la parole ensuite ce sera en
dehors de comment ça se passe à partir
de quand alors pour l'instant oui c'est
johnny depp on ne sait pas exactement
quand bear doit prendre la parole mais
les médias disent que ça sera la semaine
prochaine en tout cas est sûrement lundi
prochain alors johnny depp et ses
avocats insistent sur les problèmes
psychologiques chez amber heard est ce
que c'est vrai qu'est ce qu'ils avancent
comme comme
accusations au sujet des de la
psychologie dans birds alors là le
docteur pury donc qui est un une
psychologue qui a été engagée par les
avocats de johnny depp affirme après
avoir alors parce que ça il faut
préciser c'est très américain c'est à
dire que ce sont les avocats de johnny
depp donc johnny depp qui embauche une
psychologue pour analyser amber heard on
imagine ou va pencher le diagnostic mais
que dit cette dame alors c'est donc déjà
effectivement c'est très contestée parce
que les avocats dans bird pointe le fait
que cette c'est sûrement biaisé ce
diagnostic parce que posée par une
psychologue engagée par les avocats de
johnny depp bien sûr et donc ce
diagnostic c'est qu'elle souffre le
soufre pardon de deux troubles de la
personnalité
donc c'est un trouble de la personnalité
borderline et un trouble de la
personnalité histrionique etc des
troubles qui selon elle rempile avec oui
c'est très technique mais ça rend là en
gros ça rend la personne
assez capable de violence capable
d'agressivité j'ai une autre question
parce que vous m'avez dit que johnny
depp était soutenu est ce qu'elle est
soutenue en beurre hard ou pas du tout l
est qui vient son qui vient la
défendrons parler de d'elon musk le musk
l'homme le plus riche du monde qui est
dans l'actualité parce qu'ils rachètent
twitter pourquoi elon musk et finalement
il n'est pas venu alors finalement elon
musk n'est pas venu donc les avocats
n'ont pas
expliquer pourquoi on ignore toujours
pourquoi il faut dire que c'est assez
tendu parce que johnny depp accusant ben
erreur d'avoir eu une liaison avec elon
musk pendant leur mariage d'accord ah
oui au
fait des liens c'est vrai nous
rejoignent et en ont fait les liens dans
les aventures amoureuses de johnny depp
et amber heard qui mène malheureusement
aase à ce procès un peu particulier donc
elon musk aurait eu une aventure avec
amber heard johnny depp n'aime pas ça
mais le match n'est pas venu mais il
admet ce n'est pas venu en revanche
james franco doit témoigner à la barre
en faveur de d'amber heard james franco
grands acteurs ils se connaissent ils se
connaissent ils sont selon johnny depp
ils ont même aussi était intime
là aussi donc ça on ne sait pas si c'est
vrai en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il a échangé des sms avec amber heard
durant son mariage avec johnny depp et
qu'elle décrivait déjà un petit peu sa
détresse allez on continue chloé si vous
nous rejoignez on parle de ce procès
tout à fait exceptionnelle entre ambert
d'être johnny depp qui se déroule à
fairfax en virginie depuis maintenant le
11 avril qui doit durer cinq semaines
avec ce déballage et on va un peu plus
loin dans le sordide dans le glauque
alors un jour après une de leurs
disputes johnny depp retrouve des
excréments dans son livre désolé mais
c'est ce qui est dans le dossier amber
heard dit que ce sont ses chiens pas
johnny depp cette question a été évoquée
dans le dans le procès c'était mardi et
écouter la réponse de johnny depp les
explications de johnny depp
figo
voilà quand on est né l'a cloué à
raconter ce genre de choses sur la place
publique on n'a plus rien à perdre ils
ont plus rien à perdre les deux là alors
je ne tape il le dit clairement pour lui
il a déjà perdu ce procès il dit qu'il
est fini il a déjà été évincé donc comme
on le disait tout à l'heure de pirates
des caraïbes et des animaux fantastiques
des deux saga
fantastique ce prequel d'harry potter se
soit fait donc ça c'est deux gros sacs à
un peu blockbuster dans lesquels enfin
qu'ils ont un peu propulsé sur le devant
de la scène s'il était déjà comme un
nouveau bien c'est nouveau
et
déjà par rapport à ça et par rapport aux
6 à la vision qu'auront les gens de lui
selon lui c'est un homme aux yeux des
gens maintenant fini qui qui est trop
vieux
qui est drogué kibaki basse à son ex
femme
s'il pense que son image est transformé
à jamais aux yeux du public et donc ça
évidemment c'est ce qu'il met en avant
ils expliquent souvent ma carrière est
finie et je porte plainte pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'ils réclament
chacun vers l'autre parce que là ce
n'est ni le procès de ni date ni celui
dont bird c'est un conflit qu'on essaie
de régler c'est ce qu'ils veulent chacun
d'entre eux il ya une question
financière même sens tout à fait donc
c'est il ya d'abord à l'origine cette
plainte de johnny depp pour laquelle ils
demandent 50 millions de dollars de
dommages et intérêts
mais amber heard à elle riposté devant
la justice elle aussi a déposé une
plainte donc c'est dans le cadre du même
procès et elle réclame le double elle
réclame 100 millions de dollars de
dommages et intérêts je vous lis sur les
sur les différents chat sur celui de
youtube notamment et je suis étonné et
qu'à moitié parce que c'est ce qu'on
disait johnny depp a une cote de
popularité humour tik tok à 100% avec
johnny depp qu'est ce qu'on me dit
également justice pour johnny depp alors
il ya que des y'a que des personnes
favorables à l'acteur c'est quand même
très étonnant alors c'est vrai que
depuis le début de ce de ce procès il
n'y a que lui qui parle il n'y a que lui
qui peut s'exprimer et là c'est vrai
qu'on a écouté des extraits qui lui
était plutôt favorable dans l'ensemble
mais alors il ya quand même ce sms que
je que je vous lis qui est mis en avant
par les par les avocats de johnny depp
il aurait écrit à l'un de ses amis
pardon pour ses propos mais une fois de
plus c'est ce qui est dans le dossier
brûlant amber noyon là avant de la
brûler je vais ensuite la 1 je vais
ensuite son cadavre calciné pour
m'assurer qu'elle est bien morte c'est
quand même extrêmement violent et malgré
ça il a encore de la sympathie et il
fait encore l'unanimité et c'est lui qui
remporte presque l'opinion populaire qui
est extrêmement important dans ce procès
du sud
justement je pense que je fais qu'il est
qu'ils pensent n'avoir rien à perdre
il a décidé d'être lui-même dans ce
procès et même parfois de ceux sur jouer
lui-même et de sur jouer ses réactions
je pense qu'il prend peut-être parfois
ça un peu à la légère mais mais en tout
cas son attitude attire la sympathie des
gens et quelquefois le fait qu'ils se
sont connectés par rapport au fait qu'il
ait déjà perdu ce procès qu'il pense
être fini je pense que ça aussi beaucoup
pas tendre et les gens sans compter je
pense que cette affaire embarrasse pas
mal hollywood aussi parce que
même si amber heard se dit victime de
violences conjugales il ya quand même
pas mal de preuve à charge contre elle
aussi donc je pense que ça fait pencher
l'opinion publique aussi en la faveur de
johnny depp
voilà c'est un peu un conglomérat de
tout ça alors je réponds à luana
oliveira qui me demande sur youtube
aujourd'hui a pas d'audience en direct à
fairfax non non non ce procès a lieu du
lundi au jeudi donc aujourd'hui c'est
repos c'est aussi pour ça qu'on essaie
de débriefer d'expliquer ce qu'il s'est
passé depuis le début de ce procès le 11
avril alors ça va durer encore combien
de temps qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
maintenant est-ce que ça va être
l'escaladent du pire à ce que ça va
aller toujours plus loin que moi alors
ce procès il se termine le 20 mai et
donc on peut je pense attendre de
nouvelles surprises avec les témoignages
de damber heures de la semaine prochaine
d'accords
escalade du pire je ne sais pas parce
qu'on a déjà beaucoup vu mais c'est vrai
qu'on a des surprises tous les jours
encore aujourd'hui donc
donc ça serait pas étonnant qu'il y ait
une escalade du pierre effectivement bon
alors vous suivez ça est ce que vous
êtes surprise de ce qui se passe ou ou
pas tellement parce que il ya vu la même
chose il y à il ya deux ans avait été le
même type de procédure sans que là on va
encore plus loin non plus quelle est la
différence avec l'époque alors c'est
presque une redite effectivement du jeu
procès 2020 il ya quand même beaucoup
d'éléments notamment ses sms et ses
enregistrements audio qu'on a pu évoquer
qui sont repris dans ce procès donc
vis-à-vis de ces éléments on n'est pas
forcément surpris mais là d'autres
éléments qui sortent et qui continue de
nous surprendre
donc je pense que étant donné qu'ils
qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup de limites
entre eux oui on peut s'attendre à de
nouvelles surprises alors où en sont ils
de leur carrière respective johnny da
parce qu'ils pourront encore on va parce
qu'elle tourne encore s'ils ont des
projets est ce que vous le savez mais
peut-être pas d'ailleurs mais où elle en
est leur car on dit denis de pile à 57
ans il me semble c'est ça peut-être pas
l'apogée de sa carrière mais quand même
c'est un acteur important alors johnny
depp il a un futur projet un film de
maïwenn qui s'appelle le la favorite
donc je le français donc un film
français dont il continue malgré tout il
est soutenu par l'un de ses annonceurs
et continue malgré tout à tourner et
amber heard a également un projet donc
qui est la suite d'aquaman d'accord
le seul bémol c'est que depuis le procès
depuis l'ouverture du procès ya une
pétition qui circule à son encontre pour
qu'elles soient évincés du tournage
d'aquaman deux d'accord en gros comme
johnny depp a été vingt sept pirates des
caraïbes et s'est retirée ou a été
évincée des animaux fantastiques
incessantes effet on réclame la même
chose pour elle exactement et la
pétition a déjà recueilli 2 millions de
signatures ce qui n'a rien sans rien
d'accord alors bon je crois qu'on a fait
le tour de ce qu'on pouvait de ce conte
de ce qu'on pouvait dire
quand même une dernière question amber
de la semaine prochaine pourrait parler
est ce qu'on imagine offensive à ce
qu'elle va prendre la même attitude oil
plutôt ce côté femmes battues c'est ça
qu'elle met en avant énormément c'est
difficile de savoir là pour l'instant on
a déjà accès à ces réactions en direct
devant la cour elle et elle montre un
visage tour à tour un peu excédé un peu
puis ce salon elle est bien présente
elle ne parle pas elle n'a jamais parlé
jamais dit un mot pour l'instant ça on
ne voit que son visage pour l'instant
dans ce procès on ne voit que son visage
est quelquefois elle se tourne vers ses
avocats a discuté avec eux on me voit un
peu ses réactions en direct mais elle ne
s'est pas encore exprimé quant à dire
quelle attitude elle va adopter c'est
difficile à dire
mais effectivement elle pourrait mettre
en avant plutôt c'est cet aspect de
victimes conjugale qu'elle a beaucoup
mis en avant notamment dans sa tribune
en 2018 cet aspect de symboles je veux
voilà voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur ce
procès entre johnny depp et amber heard
on a essayé d'être le plus complet
possible évidemment et le plus digne
aussi pas facile dans cette affaire
chloé merci que le friedman de m'avoir
accompagné une question vraiment on se
moque des américains beaucoup en disant
ils suivent ce procès tous les jours il
se passionne pour la vie privée des
acteurs vous vous écrivez des papiers
sur le site du figaro est ce que vous
voyez un engouement ce que ses papiers
sont plus que les autres ça fascine
complètement les gens mais quel que soit
le quelle que soit la nouvelle que l'on
annonce c'est un véritable engouement
mais pour tous les articles sur ce sujet
d'accord donc ne nous moquons pas trop
des américains puisque nous aussi on
suit et on se passionne et on essaye
d'analyser c'est ce qu'on a essayé de
faire aujourd'hui cette situation ce
procès tout à fait hors normes entre
amber heard et johnny depp voilà vous
pouvez continuer évidemment à suivre
cette affaire je vous remontre ce papier
cet article sur sur madame figaro sur le
site du figaro dans la rubrique madame
figaro voilà ça c'est votre papier d'il
ya deux jours mais tous les jours ils
vous n'êtes pas là si vous êtes
plusieurs à suivre ce procès c'est un
travail d'équipé j'ai vu ça la suite sur
sur figure live quand même je vous donne
le programme ses points de vue ce soir
timothée d'hellemmes et figurez vous
qu'ils parleront aussi d'elon musk alors
pas tout à fait pour là pour la même
chose ils parleront d'elon musk l'ex
compagnon dans baird mais mais là ils
parleront de son son rachat de twitter
évidemment et de sa drôle de
personnalités encore merci
chloé merci de nous avoir suivis et à
bientôt sur figaro relève